what is up everyone and welcome back to
the Jenna and Jillian podcast she's only
ever dating this sweet side would be
nice to take a little break in attending
Utah oh you can learn making noises
anyway welcome back everyone thank you
for joining us this week where we like
to talk about the Jenna doing things
amongst the other things and wouldn't
you know it's just like one of our old
podcasts with why on the table because
this week's episode is brought to you by
Club W customized wine for your palate
delivered to your house
and they work directly with vineyards so
they get their own grapes cutting out
the middleman delivering you wine that
not only you don't have to go to the
store and buy but that you will like go
to club w.com
slash Jenna Julian right now and get 50%
off of your first order
this is club w wine are you gonna talk
dig dig dig dig dig dig dig all we had
it guys I thought we made it a whole
week without that songs probably fading
out good thing I just filled in that
space where the song ended and then
started again good thing ya know anyways
thank you to Club W we actually tried
the first bottle they extend you like
bottles and three at a time yeah we
already finished one yeah we finished
one it was delicious kidding so you
basically fill out like a palette form
we'll talk about it later but this is
our Club W wine and I figured uh just
like our old podcast will have a glass
of wine on the podcast yeah here off and
you like super detail club no I'm gonna
move the whole thing wrong waiting
they're holding it will look the whole
thing I'm gonna do it can you just let
the AV guy notice minute I'm gonna move
it all around this it's directional so
if you're holding it with that yeah
alright no one worked me don't even
touch it okay I'll hold the cup close to
it
doing gets so mad at me when I touch it
oh my god
that was legend that was a legendary
sound aren't you glad I held it close
that's pretty good thanks for you making
bubble noises this is our podcast hmm
think think think it's true John I was
good all right do my do me do me do me
do me do me good God if you guys are one
of those people that likes that sound uh
you're welcome for that little feature
we'll do it again later if we we go for
seconds ha
cheers Cheers mugs and oj oj mugs these
are in the works for you guys to be able
to buy very very soon we are we are
nailing down a place where you can go
right now and buy these so soon to come
these in your house and hand for coffee
and wine that wine is lit is it I
haven't right host lit its lit oh man
yeah we're big white wine fans yeah and
uh no this is our second bar we've tried
in the tough standing delicious for
those of you because I know there are a
few because we didn't start this channel
with the numbers we have now who weren't
here at the beginning we we drink every
single podcast we had a drink with us
throughout the whole podcast and often
times we would have multiple drinks hmm
true and then it gets the point where we
were podcasting on Mondays we didn't
really get drunk every Monday so but
it's nice to occasionally you know bring
one on especially with a sponsor is
appropriate so for those 21 and up you
know you can do the same anyway this is
an open to our podcast by the way you
guys can't see it but the door to the
park is really just an experimental it's
experimental the doors open so the dogs
may come in and leave as they please
which I don't know what's gonna happen
feels nervous about it I was like
nervous let's just leave the door open
see what happens I don't know if those
you guys have like dogs or stuff like
animals that if you need to get
something done you can't like have them
near you because they're very
distracting yeah cuz mine like don't
here's our needs why you to death until
you pay attention well it's more of like
yours need to be
health and cuddles and because he's not
played yeah played with like should just
bring her toys to me when we're trying
to Ellen [ __ ]
I think it's cuz they've gotten into the
habit that they know when we come in
here that nerds yeah yeah they know what
Louis lies in the dog you know what it
is
well let's [ __ ] [ __ ] up we do we do sit
excuse me Queen you don't need to
induces to it let's see what happens
it's a Spearman if I were to guess I
would say they would come in if you call
them that's just what I would guess okay
Kermit would never come when I called
him okay that's fair Kermit he's kind of
down uh about you $75 he will not come
Kermie come deal alright looks like I'm
winning well you didn't give us a time
on it okay until the end of the song
ones coming it's a blue one Oh Kermit
came alright pay okay oh my god ah so
this is this podcast is being released a
little over week removed from the Super
Bowl but because we record a couple days
in advance we figured we would talk a
little bit about the Super Bowl
hi maybe you want to come up here I
didn't care about either of the teams in
this event all not even do I have no
skin in the game which which was
actually kind of relaxing because you
know when when my teams in it I'm not
enjoying it you know I'm I'm kind of
nervous the whole time and where did
that stain come from no skin in the game
I think it comes from the pigskin of the
football that's what that saying comes
from like when you say you have no skin
in the game
that means the pigskin which is the
football yeah it's not yours doesn't
matter you have no skin in the game it's
not your football it's not your fault
that's honestly my guess if you guys
know what that actually comes I was
thinking what the opposite of that was
someone has all skin in the game someone
someone has skin in the game your skin
but not their - no it's not there's
gonna be your name it's the pigskin not
their hair I don't think that saying was
ever referring to human skin mmm
I have like like both of my elbows and
one knee in the game okay yeah I mean we
neither of us had skin the game even if
the path we're in the game I don't think
Jenna would have even had skin in the
game my mouth is in the game okay
uh I don't think I'm the only one who
thinks this but I was a little
underwhelmed entirely from the from the
beginning to the end everything included
with the Super Bowl this year
commercials halftime show production
game it's just me Eli everybody
I mean congrats Peyton pretty epic like
career-defining 200th win and what we
mean great I don't really care the
commercials were a huge letdown and the
house I'm so lucky baby
puppymung in the Doritos one with the
ultrasound oh yeah a bunch of I think it
was abortion groups were angry at that
because oh my god if I correct me if I'm
wrong so we really hold on abortion
groups were angry yes
no correct me if I'm wrong that didn't
read the articles because I try not to
read like things that I think are gonna
like make me mad yeah but I saw a
headline of like abortion groups are
angry at that Doritos commercial with
the baby like getting excited about the
Doritos news it's humanizing an unborn
baby look at unborn so makes abortions
looks like they're killing something
that's capable of wanting to Rito's yeah
so I was like that's like everyone be
like Oh Beyonce had a world stage and
instead she chose to promote the Black
Panthers like can't we just appreciate
Beyonce for a second like does it really
always have to be about I appreciate it
Yonsei what I didn't appreciate from the
halftime show peach was Coldplay I'm
gonna love trouble for talking today
about culture but they were set up to
fail well okay off the top the halftime
show for me was I don't know if you guys
had the same problem and I think Jenna
you agree with me when it was mixed
poorly like for the first whole hassle
that's actually you couldn't hear like
their voice it was just there was all
instrumental and then there was crowd
noise but like if you if you were a huge
fan of that song you couldn't like jam
out because you couldn't hear their
voice whether it was
you know whether it was a technical
problem on their end or I'm just crazy
loud I don't even know but it was it was
a little underwhelming like if I was
watching twenty one pilots or something
in concert or on a halftime show and I
was like they're playing my song and I
was and I couldn't hear the words very
well I'd be very like annoyed because
you wanna ya want to get down but you
can't well I just thought it was you
know Kumail what's his name the guy that
is on Silicon Valley and whatever i
retweeted him his tweet really cold
place so boring right now they're
literally showing other concerts which
is so true like I get it that you want a
call plays a great band
I don't hate Coldplay but like this is a
Super Bowl man like have somebody that's
got some big jams that can just pump
everybody up and get very hyped yes I
get that you want your little
progression of the act you want it to
slow down and then speed back up and
blow the roof off but like you're
setting Coldplay up to just get [ __ ]
right now Chris Martin sits out and
plays the piano and you have [ __ ]
Nicky Byrne on E
Beyonce and Bruno Mars like just let
Beyonce and Bruno Mars do that [ __ ] you
know yeah it's like saying you know I'm
really upset that's not something yeah
I'm really upset because I'm a I'm a
huge Willie Nelson fan and why don't you
guys let Willie Nelson play the Super
Bowl I know just think that there's a
reason why some acts get invited to play
the Super Bowl and others don't
I agree um it was also interesting
because it wasn't this the first time in
a little while that they didn't have
just one headliner
they had like a couple that last couple
I can remember I was like Bruno Mars
Beyonce canary yeah yeah stuff like the
ho yeah yeah um I don't know I mean uh
you know it was just bad that
commercials the halftime show was like
oh here's some Beyonce just kidding
here's Chris Martin singing over her
finally his microphone started to work
towards the end when they're all singing
together and all you can hear is Chris
Martin
say I'm like excuse you Beyonce is
taking everyone to church right now and
all I can hear is Chris Martin riddle me
how and why you can't and Bruno Mars got
me pregnant with his dance moves and he
didn't take your sunglasses off one time
he was beautiful and amazing
he is the ultimate showman after all
other than that there was football but
neither of them I'm invested in trying
to get [ __ ]
I don't know here's the thing like I I
will admit I get weary of people
complaining about big events just to
complain like every Super Bowl people
will get sucked every [ __ ] this it
sucked so I don't want to come off like
that I understand that I am complaining
and I'm not happy or wasn't super
pleased with it but I think what it was
is like every Super Bowl has like some
sort of defining thing that makes me
enjoy a camera shark left shark is a
good example whether you know it's a
commercial whether it's an occurrence
planned or not planned
yeah exactly or or some in the game
where it was a crazy place today that
wasn't in the game but that was
memorable um I don't know this this year
just didn't have anything like there's
nothing that I'm thinking of that like
damn yeah John was reminded his face
just his face every day one just Eli
Manning's face yeah
you know I agree and I think it comes
from the fact that it's [ __ ] very
corporate and needs to be you know
addressed to everyone what is very
corporate the Super Bowl you know the
kid just like do funny awesome amazing
[ __ ] I'm sure there's so many people
that plan that every year and just push
for things to be like more exciting and
more amazing and then there's just
corporate suits being like we can't do
that because it's the Superbowl and you
need to appeal to every American on
every level you know you can't just go
do weird [ __ ]
yeah just like take a bunch of risks you
you know what I mean uh I think maybe
that like the smartest people in
advertising are not spending as much
money on the Super Ball as they used to
this is not worth it well yeah but still
like it's that's my guess like I feel
like there's a lot of big smart
advertising you know teams behind brands
that just aren't really putting much
into the Super Bowl anymore because it's
like they're like why you know if we can
if we needed something on Twitter during
the Superbowl or we can just something
on YouTube leading up to the Super Bowl
it'll get well first of all we'll pay
150th of what we would have paid and
also we could get more exposure that way
and people might like it more that way
there's less pressure that way way too
expensive for what it is when you think
about five million dollars for 30-second
dick EULA's yes for what though
and think about it when you're watching
this you know how higher your
expectations for commercials they need
to be great yeah cuz you're expecting
them to knock it out of the park and
then when you don't know when you're a
kid that's like it I just remember like
the Budweiser frog commercial yeah look
you remember them for you remember the
GoDaddy ones yes of course and then you
know I don't know when this happened
culturally when it was like all right
we'll see one funny commercial and then
the rest of them are just kind of whack
yeah and I think it was like the perfect
storm of like the commercials kind of
letting us down and also the game in the
halftime show like sometimes the
commercials or whatever but at least the
halftime shows you know one day I
thought Beyonce and Bruno Mars were
really great but it was just that their
parts were so short and then there was
no like Missy Elliott coming out there's
nobody so Spice Girls there's no [ __ ]
there's no surprise there's no love
people were speculating like Gaga was
gonna come out with be exact it felt
really short and like I was like I
didn't sign up for this I signed up to
get my mind blown and nothing got blown
up I feel very unblown I also had read
that people were upset member in the
beginning when Lady Gaga went out to
sing the national anthem and Marlee
Matlin was signing the national anthem
and she's a big deal Julie didn't know
who Marlee Matlin was but for those of
you that are familiar with her know that
she's a big [ __ ] deal in the deaf
community and just at like in any
community this is a rocking meal she's
really cool yeah and the performance of
the national anthem was meant to be Lady
Gaga and Marlee Matlin because I'm
pretty sure she won looking at cabbie
more like she's [ __ ] choose important
Oh
and when they said she's going to be
signing the national anthem
they then never cut back to her signing
the national anthem well he shut her at
the start and then they never exactly
which was like you guys could have put
her in a little bubble and yeah I'm very
sure being her like you know how are you
serving the deaf community if you're
like not going to show her signing the
national anthem at all seems like a lot
of work to get in there to sign it for
not that much payoff if you're not going
to show it well yeah anything at all I
remember you you were like it's that
morally mountain I was like wait you
know the name of the person who's
signing the national anthem
[ __ ] yeah I do she's like yeah obviously
she's more than just someone who signs
but yeah that's that's interesting I did
not know that yeah I guess I can't save
a lot of people but I know that some
people are angry that they were like and
now to also sign the national anthem
here's Marlee Matlin and then they just
never cut back to it I would be [ __ ]
yes man if I was deaf and I'm like
finally someone's gonna sign this for me
I'm living right now Marlee Matlin she's
a queen psych you don't even get to see
five seconds over doing it yeah you know
mm-hmm it's looking like sixteen point
nine million tweets were sent out
according to Nielson during the
Superbowl number fifty this last weekend
or two week ago for you guys sixteen
point nine million tweets throughout the
Superbowl there's something like a
hundred something million peak viewers
if I'm not mistaken I should check that
I actually I don't
yeah I don't have that figure well I'm
just thinking like every year that
number goes up right does it
the tweet number ah not that not the
viewership that's that's different but
you know I can only assume you know why
don't I go on I look up Super Bowl xlix
well that makes sense because it's
Twitter well yeah but I mean new
technology of course it is super 49 I
mean new as in relation to the Super
Bowl yeah um I know I should have looked
at these figures up before but just kind
of the thoughts coming at me now is like
you know there's so many so many tweets
there's so many people discussing what's
going on as
happening but not necessarily in inside
the medium of television like could you
potentially see the Super Bowl like
somehow moving moving more digital where
people shall not go 90 app or whatever I
saw people tweeting about it I'm
watching the Super Bowl go 90 I'm like
oh go [ __ ] yourself I don't I don't want
I don't know what go 90 is yeah I know
that Michelle Phan is on there
commercials so at anything she does
she's Queen to love you go do you think
whatever I don't know what it is I don't
want to watch a Super Bowl on a mobile
app I'm not saying what that's I'm not
saying watching the Super Bowl on your
phone my going digital I'm just saying
like both with advertisers and just the
event know itself I think a good example
of that is insurance because last year
they did that yes they did the you know
retweet and then we'll take a winner
hundred thousand dollars and everyone
was like finally a level of interaction
between us and the Super Bowl and it was
trending for like days win this year I
looked at it again because I was
interested on the trending topics it
didn't break past like the fourth
highest training topic like people just
literally didn't give a [ __ ] this your
Super Bowl didn't people didn't give a
[ __ ] about the esurance
so the esurance didn't again this year
they didn't get a lot less well yeah
did you retweet it I didn't know they
did it again well you weren't paying
attention
no it was my intention and that just
kind of shows like I think last year was
out there this is what we're doing this
year I didn't see it I watched the whole
Super Bowl Missy Lee it was like within
the first five minutes of the Super I
was probably getting some wings but I
don't know now you were probably eating
and blacked out i black out when I eat
that's how that's true yeah I don't know
I guess like it's just it's just I don't
know the way this Super Bowl
underwhelmed me made me think that you
know I you know you never think that the
Super Bowl can leave you so like I was
like that wasn't that great well what's
going to happen is that if they keep
trying to appeal to you know the vast
majority of everyone if they just
blanket everybody and they're not
willing to ever have any controversy
I imagine maybe some people just mul
tune in the air that their [ __ ] teams
not in
yeah like I think that it's always going
to be really really culturally
significant in America I know that I'll
watch it or most people that I know will
watch it just what you do will you watch
the Superbowl do you think that if it
keeps getting awful and shitty how much
I'm not even keep my TV on the whole
time I'll turn into the halftime show
you know Patriots aren't playing or
[ __ ] bills go bills I fought with
some bills do you think like what if you
were to say around do you think it's
possible that the Super Bowl has reached
his peak I can't I don't I can't say
that I don't know I mean it's just like
because they say well because the Super
was born and bred on an old media
platform TV right and so now a lot of
things are struggling to thrive on TV
and even things that used to thrive on
TV you're struggling to continue isn't
football still the number one most most
watched whatever he's just not just good
answers I know first certain on Monday
nights that it's the most-watched
anything tonight
Roeder the u.s. in the u.s. talking
about yeah yeah so what's your heart the
NFL isn't it the most watched anything I
don't have that figure but I wouldn't
doubt it I'm pretty sure it's really up
there know how I know that cuz [ __ ]
thin glass asked that as a trivia
question to her cheerleaders that's how
you know it's when they have to prove
the wrong way that can be wrong she's
like wow you know if you want to be part
of the - Cowboys Cheerleader
organization you have to prove to us
that you're smart too because you can't
just have a bunch of diamond girls
running around okay and you gotta be in
front of press conferences inside here
you gotta hook hold yourselves like a
lady and then she'll be like what's the
number one thing the people watch on a
Monday night and someone will be like
American Idol and she's like you're cut
girl I'm sorry that's oh man it's bring
so much gonna fail anyways that's how I
knew that so I guess I was a dumb girl
before fin glass came along and well
everything I'm a lady is an absolute
fact that is for sure um but I can't say
for sure that anything's gonna happen in
the football world because you know
people are still watching football
absolutely I mean I know it might be
watch happening
bulbulay yeah more but I don't think
it's gonna stop those advertising
dollars and those people that's that
sounds more my question Chris is me off
for the Superbowl as a person that's not
religiously watching football the rest
of the time that I know that because my
eyeballs are tuned in right now the
people are just making bajillion of
dollars yeah you know mm-hmm that's sort
of annoying yeah I mean this is the
first year really felt like maybe
advertisers are not gonna continue to
just buy into this you know friends it
would be great if they didn't be [ __ ]
awesome well yeah I mean do more
interactive you have one person buy up
all the commercial spots and like play a
short film that's hysterical the whole
time have you ridiculous right what if
one company was like look we're going
[ __ ] bankrupt like we got you know
ten million dollars left in the company
yeah they would get a minute was worth
of commercials fine fair
whatever 60 seconds let's go broke and
just make the most hysterical thing in
the [ __ ] world on the Superbowl I
mean but that's the way to go but I mean
that's the idea and that's what I always
felt like with with like Super Bowl
commercials was that these companies
were starting in late February for 11
months working on a spot that they knew
would have all the eyeballs in the world
and this year I just felt like that they
didn't really give a [ __ ] right here's
what I think the problem is I think the
problem is that it's and it's an old
tradition it's an it's popular and an
old media platform and in the past when
they've tried to cater to a newer
younger audience like you have mi a
flipping off people in the crowd you
have you know Madonna and people that
are older parents generation in Middle
America find very jarring and offensive
you know everything that they do is just
[ __ ] sexualized and disgusting and
awful and I think that the NFL went that
way member they had Britney Spears and
Aerosmith and NSYNC like that she was
[ __ ] rad yeah we were all so excited
that's when you know the Super Bowl is a
big thing and also everyone's eyes were
pointed in the same direction right you
just have [ __ ] TV you don't have
twitter also yeah and other ways to
consume media
everyone is just watching the super
level plane so once they started in you
know now we have internet we have phones
they started trying to cater a little
bit to that audience and then you know
they see the backlash immediately of
that they shouldn't have booked all of
these mi a you shouldn't have booked
Madonna you should not have Nicki Minaj
with the Super Bowl this pisses my
middle America ass off and I don't like
it and they decided I think to take a
safer route I think it felt safe I think
that their yeah instead of trying to
push the envelope and keep moving
forward in a way that will keep
everybody watching the Super Bowl
they're just trying to cater to the
audience that they know what - exactly
I'm like why why don't we push down the
like what's what's in it for us right
well because what's in it for them is a
whole lot of like anger and backlash and
what they've been getting up exactly
yeah I was like not to lose lives we
can't well they can't have another Janet
Jackson and they realize that
immediately after it happened that was
the step one of them you know making it
more straightly crazy yeah but you know
now that it's boring and we're sitting
here as adults being like why did I
[ __ ] spend my day watching this when
I don't care about the team's
you know care about the cultural aspect
the commercials you know what everyone's
doing today it's like it feels like a
waste it feels like I got duped into
doing something I don't know why you
know feels like when you wake up some
day and you question all everything
you're like wait what do we do what do
we do on Easter again why are we hunting
for Easter eggs oh I'll get it is it
cool if I just tap out this year you
know that's not I think they can only
take advantage of the fact that they
know everyone's gonna watch it if they
if they cater to everybody the best that
they can and it just feels like they've
given up Katy Perry was a risk to me
though it doesn't shock that they booked
Katy Perry yeah it does feel that way my
like she was allowed to have whipped
cream squirting out of her [ __ ] boobs
yeah she had to tone it down girl yeah
she came in on a giant lion I mean but
that was a top and she started with like
in the boxing ring right honey from the
bottom Ellie yeah no that was a
different performance that was a totally
different before Wow no it does feel if
you've got like you know it's just
someone gave up or you know advertisers
are given up person is because some of
the people that listen to the podcasts
are younger than us some of you are
older than us some of us are our same
age I think that just about covers
everyone could work Janet thanks Janet
I'm curious to know your thoughts though
like if in the future the Superbowl want
of tears for my thoughts their thoughts
go if in the future the Super Bowl wound
up to be you know pretty straight-laced
kind of boring and you didn't really
find it culturally important enough to
tune into would you shut it off would
you do something else would you feel the
need to leave watch the Super Bowl just
to watch it in the future you don't I go
in sure this might people that didn't
even watch it this year well going
online going on Twitter seeing you know
tweets from people and trending topics
and whatnot like I felt like that I mean
that's kind of the case every year where
people are just like oh it's time to
watch the Superbowl because that's what
everyone does and it felt like that
again this year but I can absolutely see
it being like okay it's Super Bowl
Sunday wait a minute we don't have to do
this you know like and then that gets
more and more prevalent because the
Super Bowl gives you more you know less
and less reason each year to be like oh
let's watch it I could rather be on
Twitter catching all the footnotes and
seeing all the gifts of what I've missed
while I'm doing something blue you're is
enough you'll go watch a video on there
yeah exactly I think this year was the
first year that you and I like haven't
gotten together with other people we
Saturday there was no party there was no
alcohol whatsoever like just we sat at
home we watched it yeah we hung out and
then it was over and then you go about
your life that was the first time that I
did no other celebrations like even
food-wise like when we get from pizza
I'm leaving all out yeah we didn't that
was it and then we're done
yeah it was the first time at least in
my adult life reading my cute life that
I can remember
like not having it be a big to-do it was
just uh oh I woke up and the Super Bowl
is on so I'm gonna watch that yeah it
was definitely the first time I felt
that way watching it every single year
I've been with more people easily and
more food and drinks and noise this year
we were just on the couch watching and I
loved it because it was like didn't feel
like it deserved anymore you know so
it's interesting I definitely am
curiously here you guys chime in because
whether you're younger than us older
than us same age as us I still feel like
it's something that's interesting to
talk about right now well I so I really
think that it's interesting that not
everyone's eyes are pointed in the same
direction yeah yeah because I feel like
it that's true
before there was mobile internet people
using social media and stuff like that
you can't really go anywhere and avoid
the Super Bowl because everybody else is
watching it yeah
so unless you're gonna go for our hike
in the woods yeah are you gonna go drive
around yeah
like Steve Martin stated he was like
don't tell me what happened I'm
reporting the game like as a joke like
you know like you can't for this animal
mmm no but now if you wanted to just go
sit in your room or you know watching
Netflix on your phone you don't have to
watch the Superbowl you could probably
find plenty of people via the internet
that have no interest in watching the
Super Bowl and you can go [ __ ] play
destiny with them I don't know yeah I
just think that it's an interesting
tradition for especially for me someone
that doesn't really care a whole lot
about football don't really watch it yet
every year I turn tune into this thing
why I'm ministry is the question that is
much astronomy's because I really like
baseball
I don't watch baseball religiously and
even the World Series there's plenty of
World Series that I haven't watched same
here but I like baseball a lot more than
I like football why is that because
football is the you know most important
sport in our country even though
baseball
this past time I'm just abiding by our
cultural norm yeah which is everybody
gets super drunk and eats a lot of food
on Super Bowl Sunday Super Bowl Sunday
is the number one highest day for duis
in this country which is terrifying that
is terrifying Wow
how do you say about Christmas I don't
know in a couple years wouldn't yeah but
if I can't give you a year yeah that'll
be wrong yeah ma was just on the ground
what he's licking they're looking at in
the mirror that's not lifting when you
say himself in the mirror - hmm wouldn't
you if you were that handsome fair point
rubble you're a handsome guy but yeah I
mean the DUI thing is very scary
especially on um on Super Bowl Sunday
because you don't think of it as like a
everyone's going out and getting
hammered like New Year's and then
driving home it's like Super Bowl Sunday
you're with your family you're eating
chips like why is that the highest DUI
day well I'm not saying I don't agree
with it obviously it's right now it's a
fact it's just it is surprising cuz it's
so culturally ingrained in our society
but the commercial this year with Helen
Mirren saying like don't drink and drive
give a damn I can't really remember I
could be wrong but I can't remember too
many commercials in the past of the
Super Bowl having any sort of social
responsibility for that being it's all
just like beer beer beer here beer beer
yeah yeah yeah tailgating beers yeah
drinking this year they accomplished one
of the two things I think that could
have improved it one was the Helen
Mirren really straight up kind of
sobering ad yeah he doesn't remind you
don't be a [ __ ] dick yeah stop
driving drunk you [ __ ] but it was I
mean it I thought like there was a big
campaign for like you know social media
people they were like it was brand deals
he was tweeting out hashtag like give a
damn is up which is like it is what it
is people are doing their brand deals
but at the same time I saw other like
influencers and creators and you know
people on the internet tweeting that
hashtag who clearly weren't part of the
brand deal so that's when you know that
the message
kind of transcended just like it's a
campaign it's a advertising job to like
okay really though like really this
means something like that commercial was
you know it did hit home and I'm sure
hit home a lot of people out you know
who knows what kind of difference it
made hopefully I made a big one but it's
the first time that they've taken some
sort of show know about I don't know
about that it may be the first time it
can that lightly analyzer please drink
no I'm not so it's not taking no I don't
think the footnote is the funky well I
don't think the footnote is the only
time that they've if they relentlessly
promote drinking and that they're like
I'm not delivering for but is dying and
drunk accident
seems like Oh better get [ __ ] promote
Budweiser I'm not no you're right I'm
not disagreeing with you that they've
done a you know in it was money to pay
for Beyonce yeah I'm not disagreeing
with you that they've done a responsible
job at saying you know drinking and
driving is no joke ah but I don't think
this year was the first time that they
really made a spot dedicated to just
shaking you and being don't trigger
drive I just think this this year's spot
work the best hmm at least to my memory
maybe you're right but I just don't know
that for sure
you know mmm-hmm here's the thing
drinking and driving sucks this whole
problem be solved if you got your wine
deliver to your house W you can do that
sign up online go to Club W comm slash
Jenna Julianne not only will you get 50%
off fifty guys half off your first order
but you will get online you will fill
out a palate form which basically asks
you questions about your palate and this
isn't just pertaining to wine
it's about coffee it's about food it
basically gathers key questions that
they use to formulate what wines and
what different sort of groups of wines
within groups of wines subgroups if you
will that would please you and that
would make you you know happy even if
you didn't know that that was what you
wanted so you fill out this list and
they said you want okay you get the
first batch of wine you taste it you
fill it another ways it's very short
they're like a couple questions used to
take two seconds and it's basically
moving forward how did you like this one
what would you change and then by the
the second delivery you should have a
wine that's so dialed into your taste
that you would never not only have been
able to pick it out for yourself at the
grocery store but don't have to for us
that's literally what we did they sold
us on that you know they told us what
they were about we're like okay let's
see so we did it this is our first batch
of wine and I have zero complaints and
I'm not I'm not you know I'm not some
you know some oh yeah look at me I'm
like twirling my wine but I do like good
wine and I can tell when it's [ __ ] wine
and the fact that they work with
vineyards have their own grapes cut out
the middleman it's fresh it's what we
want and I talked about this before last
time Club W sponsored us my previous way
of picking wines was which bottle of the
coolest Wow Wow I don't think that's a
bad strategy is terrible the only worse
it's definitely worse than deferring to
someone who is an expert which is Club W
and these are exciting bottles so you
kind it's kind of like a you know you
still get to have that little pizzazz in
the bottle I mean that one's really dope
top says ass Oh check it out guys if you
like wine don't go pick it up yourself
don't go stand at that aisle while
you're looking at the wine with five
other people it's heavy
Hugo nobody wants to go get why the
grocery store get on Club W go to club W
calm slash Jenna Julian and have them
bring it tailored to your tastes
tailored to your address so you can
drink it and enjoy it
plus it's really nice like we'll have we
had three bottles that were delivered
for the month right and it's like you
each week sort of you get a perfect
amount for the more like alright what
nice should we drink this but like what
dinner yeah guys you can try on get 50%
off if you don't like Y you can be done
that's really exciting squad yeah so
thank you Club daddy for sponsoring the
podcast Thank You Club W go check them
out makes the podcast for you guys so we
appreciate that
wow I am a time I'm wearing a sweater in
here and I'm quickly realizing that
might have been take your sweatshirt on
not wearing your shirt off take it all
off I'm not gonna be naked on the
podcast
get on the podcast naked on the podcast
naked on the podcast press one now
if you want Julian to be live and they
don't want to keep up yet on the podcast
my mumble has one for everyone
Wow Colonel bud now they know the door
should I see my wrong yet not have a
[ __ ] haven't talked so marbled okay
what's up dude no struggle moisturize
Illinois struggle noises so this is kind
of a chill podcast I don't know we were
traveling in a couple days cast to talk
cast we're traveling to Canada in a
couple days which is why we're recording
it early and it's not normal for us to
record this release go in to Edmonton
Alberta Canada we're going to may see
one or make make you wanna rock you on
something
I think so yeah okay someone's gonna
have to help us yeah I think it's not an
outfit Mack you on University in
Hamilton and uh Jenna's going to speak
to the students which really Quaker
let's talk about that because I I've
been to more than a handful of these
events where you go to colleges and you
speak to the students and I think it's
one of the coolest things that you get
to do with your with your career
whatever you want to call it your job
with your life it's very very cool that
you get to go to a college speak to
these kids who are in the realm of the
mindset that you are in or were in a
couple years ago and you get to really
connect these kids and I don't know
there's something like I get from like
watching not not teenagers talk to you
and ask you questions and listen to you
and respond and nothing against teenage
obviously nothing I love all the people
who support you and support me and come
out to these events and stuff but there
is something where it's like you know
they're they're slowly entering the real
world right right now and you you're
like so familiar with that transition
and that kind of frame of mind and what
everything goes long you mean you went
to college you went to grad school you
know what it is
and so the questions are different and
the responses are different and the
energy is different you know and I think
it's something that's it's just a very
cool thing you know
well thanks John I mean when when I do
these things people a lot of times are
like oh you know what do you talk about
like what do you do have like a speech
or is it like a performance or like what
are you doing and to be quite honest
with you I a long time ago when I first
had the opportunity to get invited to
university or college I was like holy
[ __ ] that is the coolest thing because I
would categorize it into something
that's like a life goal right no yeah
officer at a college is just like a life
goal and I was like you know at that
time not too far removed from being in
college and I thought back to my past
self and I was like thinking of little
[ __ ] Jenna that's got to go to
softball practice that just had class
like all [ __ ] day I just tread
through some snow to get here like
somebody cool came to our school fine
but what I never wanted was to sit in a
room and have them talk at me you know
no matter how interesting they are or
like how cool it is the experiences that
I got the most out of in college were
interactive like we had a transgender
woman that had gone from female to male
and it was in a small class of like 20
students and I had never met a like
trans person like in the flesh before
you know I had found other people on the
internet I was familiar with that
transgender male she's feet if started
female yeah yeah better um and he was
the most fantastic [ __ ] person I'd
ever met because we were allowed in a
small classroom to just sit there and
raise our hand and ask any question that
we would and none of it was like
inappropriate it was all just like
really well thought out because we
didn't have the YouTube community you
know we didn't we didn't get to go on
there and have GG and these people that
are so open and willing and just as long
as you're not being offensive if you
have a question
they're more than happy to just help you
understand
I literally at the end of that talk I
was like thank you so much I will gladly
pay back my tuition after this
experience and that always stuck with me
and I was like if you know I ever get an
opportunity to talk to people I don't
really think the most important thing to
do is to go and like talk at them I
think that might be more entertaining
for a lot of people but what might make
it the most impactful or helpful in
anyone's life is to make it as
interactive as possible yeah and so for
most of these things we do sort of uh
moderate the Q&A in the beginning and
usually they pull those questions from
students for me right because the I will
tell you Julian will tell you anyone
will tell you and you can tell yourself
because you know this schools are so
ridiculously different from each other
like when we were in Arizona versus like
- yeah it's just very very yeah very
different from school to school from
population of people to whatever yeah um
so again to get up there and presume
that I know what these people want to
talk about is just insane so we do a
moderated QA and then the last half of
it isn't open yeah yeah and we just sit
there we talk like sometimes they just
want me to like you know keep going go
on like top talk to us tell us things
and other times it's like you know the
Arizona crowd they just want to [ __ ]
scream and yell and yell out like come
get [ __ ] shots with us you know it
just all depends but I think that the
I've decided and I was started that way
and then I decided that the best way to
you know have a talk with college
students because we are all in a similar
boat of like not really knowing where
we're going what we're doing yeah is to
just make it as like warm and welcoming
and interactive as possible because
although I am like up on a stage talking
to them we're all in the same [ __ ]
boat like we're all [ __ ] confused and
it's really nice to do that in that
sense I can give some advice but for the
most part it's very like just I find
your mindset
on that like really really interest I'm
here to inspire you to just do your own
thing again yeah and the whole like not
talking at you thing I find that
interesting that you that you think of
it that way and I think that's really
important do you feel like the fact that
you went to college and graduate school
and had the experience of someone coming
to school and interacting with the
students whether it was talking at them
or interacting but because you had that
experience and you didn't grow up
watching YouTube and you didn't grow up
idolizing different people like the way
people do with YouTube now or watching
the way they do now like you had the
experience on the other end of this
college situation you didn't have the
experience on the other end of the
YouTube situation so this do you feel
like because you were actually in that
spot on the other side that that this is
even more special when you go to
colleges because you were in that crowd
a few years ago and you you know you
mean like you weren't a youtube
subscriber but you are in that crowd
like so going on that stage I feel like
it's you know does it does it feel even
more special because it's told your
information of like it's totally
ridiculously special in every way shape
or form the most of which to me though
is that in college every minute of your
time really matters and I was told by my
softball coach she was like in college
you have more free time than you've ever
had in your whole life which is very
true on one hand because if you don't
have a job and you're just taking
classes you have a buttload of [ __ ]
free time unfortunately
most college students have jobs they
have two jobs they play a sport they do
internships so all of that free time
gets taken up very quickly and you're
not really getting any money for any of
that time you're just paying money for a
moment get to think about money exactly
so the fact that I understand the value
of a college students time and the value
of you know five dollars or whatever
depends on which school they're at for
the they have the students pay for some
of them and not for others of them but
it even if it's five dollars I
understand the value of that five
dollars per student to go and listen to
someone that is almost essentially their
peer that is maybe just you know five
ten years ahead of them
in terms of life it is a big deal and it
is very special to me and when we have
that time with college students I get so
much out of it as well because it's
you're in a room full of people that are
all on the same wavelength yeah which is
very different than when you're in a
room full of teenagers when you have a
room full of teenagers nothing against
teenagers who are you just have YouTube
intelligent human beings yes right like
that great you know I smile but they do
have this internet thing where they
really idolize people on the Internet
they really tend to think this is like
you know I would do anything for Cameron
Dallas to just like absolutely I would
just want to breathe his air come on you
know and the college demographic is just
enough removed from that to always treat
me like a person like a human and we
have an actual conversation and then the
older demographic of people are the ones
that look at me and like just really
treat me like trash like just really
[ __ ] take down on me they turn their
nose to it it's it's nice all of its
nice interacting with people is really
nice at any age group at any level the
oldest people I think are to some of the
toughest for me because they don't
understand me and if they do it's coming
from a place of like they very much want
to understand they really want to work
they're just frustrated they don't quite
get it yeah that it's they but they are
curious at the very least yeah and then
the people that are really hurtful are
the older people that are just like what
mean if you work if you were to sit down
if you were to sit down and pick like I
would like to connect with this stage of
someone's life so basically I would like
to connect with 20 year old Jenna rather
than tit you know 10 15 year old Jenna
20 you know what I'm saying like so
you're connecting with your like your
call it like college students okay and
you were in college so you know what
your mind is like in college so to have
that demographic really connect to you
the way they do I would say it's pretty
cool because you are Sophie
earlier with where you were mentally in
college because I feel that way exactly
and you like you and not only you know
you stay that way but like college
absolutely shapes you in somebody wins
and and for you to think about like yes
you have influence over crazy different
amounts of people in different age
groups and all sorts of things but the
way you get it in person with the
college visits is like you know I feel
like if you were to choose like that's
not bad you know you get to you get to
really sit there and talk to and connect
and have and have a moment with someone
who you are so familiar with because you
were just there and that really I mean
it shaped you yeah you know I mean you
can speak to this and I know and I know
a lot of people listening feel the same
way the the downside of being in college
is that you are told everything you are
told this is how you do this I'm your
professor I have a [ __ ] PhD I know
everything the path in life is this okay
you want to be in TV broadcasting
whatever here's your path hey Jana you
want to be in psychology
here's your path you are told from day
one what you need to do to get to your
point B and it it's so restricting in
higher education because you really
start to believe that this is my only
choice
like I've chosen a major this is the
path that I'm walking down it's too late
to turn back now and you start getting
so like claustrophobic like your world
is closing your low servo be like I have
to finish this path or else I'm lost and
that is just not the case and I think
that because I still live that and
breathe that every single day that you
know I'm taking a risk every day that I
wake up by doing something different
because I'm so far out of the path at
this point I know now that there is
snuff returning back to my path but you
still relate right it's comforting as a
college student get someone in there
that is just willing to tell you like
hey man okay turn on over the [ __ ] it's
okay to not [ __ ] know and whatever
you think your path is your life is you
don't necessarily have to take that and
feel so trapped yeah you know I mean it
has to feel that
I'm just imagining you know what it
would have been like like I was just
like every other person in the entire
world in college you're lost you know
you don't know what the [ __ ] going on
you going through emotional crisis you
know yeah every day every single day and
you're a [ __ ] mess you're depressed
you're happy or sad you have friends you
have enemies all sorts of shared drunk
yeah all we could have ever hoped for
and would have ever wondered what it
would have been like to have someone who
I looked up to or knew about and
respected come to my school in the flesh
and say hey you kid lost kid who is
crying last night for no [ __ ] reason
nothing her trial if I called him I was
pretty tough I never call no everyone
does I mean you're [ __ ] you're a
messing but like what I'm saying is like
all like I'm just imagining what that
would have done to be like you know I
had Rainn Wilson come to my college and
I was so huge for me because I you know
I was I was a kid who was such a Herman
go ahead nobody I was a kid who was a
hermit in college and and for a lot of
years
namely like you know sophomore and
junior I did a lot of just sitting in my
dorm room my apartment just watching the
office you know whether it was
background to writing a paper or was
whatever was I had the office on almost
24/7 and they have Rainn Wilson come to
my school and talk was great I mean it
was so cool like it took me out of
reality for a second every give you guys
a talk did he job you can yeah yeah yeah
but I mean you don't fault him for it
it's it you know he's an older guy he's
in a different generation but what I'm
trying to get at here which is a I'm
trying to make a point oh I'm sorry
um it's like if someone like him who I
respected said it's okay for you guys
not to know what the [ __ ] you're doing
you know whatever you're doing no matter
how lost you are from day to day like
don't worry if you have no clue what
you're gonna do when you get out of here
like I can't imagine with that but it
when I hear you say that to kids in
college now I'm like damn that is cool
that is cool because they're sitting
there 100% stressed about their test
tomorrow they're stressed about this
they're stressed about that and this
just about big picture things and then
they have Jenna models there and she's
you know she's their best friend on the
internet and she's just like hey guys
I'm serious like don't worry about it
whatever
happens you're gonna figure it out you
don't need to know you're gonna do
whoever says you know you know you do on
all the time [ __ ] and all I just I
feel like there's a lot to be said about
someone who has influential power over
people like that who are in moments in
their lives or aren't daisy's every day
to hear that no I appreciate that
well I think is really interesting
though is that sometimes I do say that
and other times I don't it's just
totally dependent yes yeah and they win
and if they choose to go somewhere
because we've had some that are just all
light all up all happy all funny all fun
that's what the crowd wants and we do
that and then we've had other very
serious schools yeah they literally want
to pick your brain I want to know what
you think about this and this and this
and there's other schools that just want
like very hippie dippie life advice and
that's it yeah it's so dependent on the
people and who's there who's present you
know it's really interesting it's one of
the coolest things that I get to do in
my job I guess on a dream which I I
can't remember a school that like
actually was like hey come and I was
like yeah [ __ ] no everything's always
just like a scheduling conflict yeah
like if they're like please come for
free tomorrow you know we have to like
you have to learn karate yeah yeah you
know I can't go broke going to every
College in the country well yeah you can
take a fee just like you know another
person would yeah but it was it's one of
the coolest things I get to do I feel
like I say that at every school because
every time that I am in one of these
appearances it get like so overwhelmed
with what's actually happening because I
don't tour I don't do like what a lot of
other people do so they I know that they
get that but it's it's I don't get that
validation the same way that are you to
using your met people school well
because I don't I don't I guess I don't
go perform them check it out yeah yeah
no no no I don't I don't get I don't
perform live so I don't get the live
feedback yeah so when I do it is really
special because I it's not something I
regularly do and it feels really cool to
be
roomful of people when you're all having
a shared experience yeah but it's also
nice that you're not you're not in a
show you know you're just there to talk
well yeah because I don't really want to
put on a show I could I think would be
[ __ ] America I'm not going to say
never I would totally do it someday but
at this point in my life I just I love
being home with my dogs and I promise
you I will very slowly make my way
around the country in the world to meet
anybody that wants to meet me or Julian
and I will do my best to do that but it
just takes a long time because you have
to you know I have to posted videos we
do the podcast that's a lot just my
radio show like there's a lot of things
that have to happen in order for us to
be able to travel and when I do get to
though it's very special yeah well I
mean I not everybody wants to go to
VidCon and playlist yeah don't you
understand that yeah well I mean I
honestly hope that if you are somewhere
where Jenna hasn't visited or you're
curious as to what it is that goes on
when she goes to a college I hope this
conversation sort of illuminated
something for you because I've always
viewed it as something that's very
special I feel lucky to kind of witness
it and be there and see the effects
especially you know that you're my
girlfriend that it's very it's a proud
moment obviously but it's more nice to
lie but it's more than that you know
it's like it's it's just kind of a cool
thing and really cool you know let us
know questions about that stuff you know
if you were wondering you know how it
started where what's our first school
well whatever it is just we'd love to
hear you participate in the conversation
because it's cool it's good it's good
stuff and I'm just amazed that anybody
in college thinks that I'm like cool or
wants me to come students don't want
though I mean when I'm sure there's like
proposals and student government's and
when your name gets proud of it and
clearly wins out a lot so
that's [ __ ] crazy anyway we're going
to do this weekend in Canada I'm coming
to Canada Canada do Canada ha ha don't
forget your passport I'm gonna get a
stamp on it forget I'll do my best to
document our time there so you guys can
get a little bit whoa double AAG my ear
itches sorry I did it all right I'm done
sorry that's okay we love you guys thank
you for hanging out with us for one more
week of the journal podcast we
appreciate your guys time so much
shout out to Club W our sponsor this
week guys have-have wine selected for
you by the experts who have their access
to fresh grape vines they're setting you
wine that you know you want on and you
don't even know it you don't want it and
you don't even know it this is this is
wine that's really great and it's
high-quality shading you're not paying
high quality prices so check it out at
Club W comm slash Jenna Julianne 50% off
your first order and delicious wine on
its way to your house you don't have to
get up and it supports Alaska is it
supports the pockets which we very much
appreciate you guys are always very
receptive to sponsors we we want you to
know we really do appreciate that
mm-hmm we'll see you guys next week for
another one yeah ding ding ding ding oh
he has playing it I'm gravy guys
you